luxury labels like Dior and Louie
Vuitton getting into Christmas fashion
designers are proving that clothes
aren't the only thing they can make
Christmas trees are all the rage right
now the creative mind behind this model
is not difficult to guess it's the work
of Jean Paul Gautier look off sick on me
you probably recognize my corset
immediately my grandmother used to drink
vinegar to make her waist smaller so
maybe if we water the tree with vinegar
we could pull the corset a bit tighter
but I've stuck to the rules there are
lights a Christmas tree all very
traditional most of the designer
Christmas trees are certainly a lot less
traditional Ellie sobs design has a
distinctly purest feel about it
unlike Stella cadet days luscious model
there's a Christmas tree mobile made out
of crocodile leather from Hermes and in
origami tree from Kenzo my assistants
and I worked very hard origami is very
traditional in Japan and if you fold
1,000 cranes it's supposed to bring good
luck
but the Japanese designer won't be
spending Christmas in the snow he's
heading off to sunnier climes I'll be in
Thailand on the beach wearing a pareo
Jean Paul Gautier is planning a
traditional Christmas with his family in
the southwest of France Christmas in
France brings back lots of childhood
memories for me the Christmas tree the
presents good food we always have veal
sausage with truffles and oysters
I'm looking forward to it already I'll
have to forget about my diet for a while
then there's the wonderful Christmas
cake la bouche de noel filled with mocha
it's delicious food is always very
important for us the 40 designer
Christmas trees will be auctioned off
for charity on December 9th the proceeds
this year are to go to a French cancer
charity the event is the brainchild of
Paris fashion journalist Marie Christian
mamak she's been organizing it for the
past 18 years
would you care the fashion designers
who've created these trees have big
hearts but I think it also makes them
feel good it eases their conscience not
only selling clothes and bags but also
using their talent to raise money for a
good cause we work in quite a
superficial industry we create something
and we throw it away we love what we
once despised and despise what we once
thought was great so it's good to do
something that has meaning and substance
some designer trees sell for just a few
hundred euros while others fetch
thousands a Christmas tree from Jean
Paul Gautier once went for 10 thousand
euros will this year's design live up to
that we'll have to wait until next week
to find out